[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم احالت محكمه جنايات بنها في مصر
الى مفتي الجمهوريه اوراق عشره متهمين من
رافضين الانقلاب من ناحيه اخرى قبلت محكمه
مصريه استئناف ضابط مكوم في قضيه سياره
ترحيلات ابو زعبل التي قتل فيها 37 من
معارضي الانقلاب وقررت اعاده القضيه
لاستكمال التحقيق نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لكي
نناقشه في محورين ما المؤشرات التي يمكن
استخلاصها من روح وتوقيت هذه الاحكام
بخصوص توجه السلطه في مصر خلال الفتره
المقبله وما المطلوب لراب الانقسام
المجتمعي الذي عمقه التعامل الامني
والقضائي مع معارضي الانقلاب
[موسيقى]
قبل اقل من 24 ساعه من تنصيب عبد الفتاح
السيسي الفائز بانتخابات الرئاسه في مصر
في مصر رئيسا للبلاد اصدرت محكمه مصريه
موجه اخرى من احكام الاعدام بحق مجموعه من
معارضي الانقلاب الاحكام التي اتسمت
بالقسوه وشملت عددا من قيادات هذا التيار
تزامنت مع حكم قضائي اخر سمته التساهل قبل
بموجبه استئناف ضابط شرطه محكوم بالسجن ع
سنوات في قضيه قتل فيها
37 من [__]
الانقلاب قرت المحكمه غيريه وجماع اراء
اعضائها فيحال اوراق الى فضيله الور حكم
يسبق الاعلان عن احكام بالاعدام غيابيا
بحق عشره متهمين من رافض الانقلاب من بين
المحكوم عليهم اسماء بارزه كمف الاخوان
المسلمين عبد الرحمن البر والقيادي في حزب
الاصاله السلفي محمد عبد المقصود مصير
بقيه المتهمين الذين يحاكمون حضوريا فيما
يعرف بقضيه قطع طريق قليوب سيعرف ايضا في
الخامس من يوليو المقبل ومن بينهم محمد
بديع مرشد جماعه الاخوان الذي يحاكم في
نحو 40 قضيه منذ عزل الرئيس مرسي المفارقه
انه في نفس يوم احاله اوراق عشره متهمين
الى مفتي الجمهوريه الغت محكمه في القاهره
حكما سابقا بحق ضباط الشرطه مدانين في
قضيه سياره ترحيلات السجن ابو زعبل قبيله
العداله طلب استئناف الضابط المحكوم عليه
بعشر سنوات لادانته في قتل 37 متهما من
معارض الانقلاب تعود القضيه الى الثام عش
من اغسطس الماضي عندما اطلقت الشرطه الغاز
المسيله للدموع على متهمين داخل سياره
الترحيل ومات اختناقا وحرقا بغض النظر عن
الروايه الرسميه لما حدث واستخدام وصف
القتل الخطا فان كثيرا من التساؤلات اثيرت
بشان الروح التي صدرت وفقها احكام القضاء
المصري خلال الشهور الاخيره قضاء حطم
الرقم القياسي في عدد احكام الاعدام التي
اصدرها بالجمله منذ عزل مرسي وقمع
المظاهرات الرافضه للانقلاب تجاوزت تلك
الاحكام الالف في قضايا تحمل اسماء مختلفه
لكن عنوانها الابرز هو محاربه المعارضين
السلطه الجديده في البلاد وهكذا قد ينظر
للقضاء على انه ساهم في تعميق حاله
الانقسام المجتمعي القائمه حاليا اثبتت
الشهور الماضيه ان سياسه الاقصاء والقبضه
الحديديه لم يخرج مصر من ازمتها من تحديات
الرئيس الجديد الذي سيتولى الحكم بعد
الساعات ان يغير هذا الواقع المتهم بصنعه
او على الاقل المشاركه في ذلك قبل ان تصل
الامور الى ما هو اسوا
موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفين في الاستديو
مختار كامل رئيس تحالف المصريين
الامريكيين والدكتور عصام عبد الشافي
استاذ العلوم السياسيه اهلا بكم سيد مختار
كامل كيف تقرا قبل 24 ساعه من تنصيب
السيسي رئيسا لمصر هنالك احكام قاسيه بحق
معارض الانقلاب واخرى تساهله مع الاخرين
اولا انا اعتقد ان التوقيت اذا كان
المقصود منه اي رساله سياسيه فهو توقيت
غير موفقه ثانيا المقارنه ايضا غير موفقه
وانا هنا
اتحدث من على اساس السلطه القضائيه بغض
النظر عن الانتماء السياسي للمجني عليهم
هذه المقارنه ومثل هذه المقارنات حينما
تكررت في عهد مبارك ادت الى ثوره ولذلك
فانا اعتقد ان التوقيت غير موفق لانه يثير
ذكريات مؤلمه وذكريات ادت الى الثوره ولا
نود ان نبدا اول يوم للرئيس الجديد بمثل
هذه الذكريات السيئه دكتور نفس السؤال نفس
السؤال الاجابه هتختلف الى حد كبير يتم
التعامل مع القضاء المصري باعتباره اليه
من اهم الاليات التي اعتمد عليها الانقلاب
العسكري منذ 3ث يوليو لتمرير العديد من
الاحكام في وجه المعارضين العديد من
القرارات تمت تم صدرت بشكل سياسي بالدرجه
الاولى
يمكن للامانه يمكن رصد عدد من المؤشرات
الاساسيه التي يعني يمكن ان تشكل رمزا
لهذا القضاء في المرحلات منذ 3 يوليو حتى
الان المؤشر الاول ان هذا القضاء تحكمه
بالاساس اعتبارات سياسيه القضاء الفاسد
يقوم على التمييز وانتهاك مبادئ المساواه
وتكافؤ الفرص القضاء الفاسد هو الذي لا
يوفر للمتهمين حق الدفاع انفسهم حتى بشكل
حقيقي وفاعل القضاء الفاسد هو الذي يجعل
قضاته من وسائل الاعلام وسيله للشهره
والانتشار على حصب الحق والعداله وكذلك
الذي يتجاهل القوانين والتشريعات ويحكم
وفقا للنوايا وال شبهات وايضا الذي يتماهى
وهذا اخطر اشكاليه تواجه القضاء المصري
منذ الانقلاب الذي يتماهى مع السلطات
الاخرى داخل الدوله يتماهى مع السلطه
التنفيذيه ويتماهى مع السلطه القضائيه ويت
يتماهى مع السلطه التشريعيه والسلطه
السياسيه وللاسف الشديد هذا التماهي في
السلطات افقد للقضاء استقلاليته فاصبح
يستخدم لاداه من الادوات التي اعتمدت
عليها سلطه الانقلاب لفرض سياستها ومواجهه
كل معارضيه سيد مختار كامل مع هذه
المطالعه
للدكتور سواء كنت توافق ام لا لكن هي تعبر
عن راي شريحه معينه ما يشعرون به تجاه
القضاء المصري يقال الان ان اول تحدي امام
الرئيس المنتخب في مصر هو مساله ربما
الامن الاستقرار الاقتصادي والمصالحه لو
دخلنا في المصالحه هل هذا يعني هذه
المراره من القضاء يخدم المصالحه في مصر
لا طبعا هذا لا يخدم المصالحه بس في في
نفس الوقت انا لا اعتقد ان الشعب بكل فئته
السياسيه ناضج من اجل المصالحه الان ولذلك
انا كررت اكثر من مره ان بدايه المصالحه
يجب ان تكون حوار مفتوح وشعبي وصريح بين
الاطراف انما المصالحه الان قفزا نرجع
لموضوع القضاء بقدر ما يكون القضاء غير
محايد بقدر ما يضر بامكانيه تحقيق استقرار
الدوله هناك علامات منذ قديم منذ عهد
مبارك اغلال القضاء سياسيا ومحاوله افساده
وهناك شكوك ل يعني في مختلف
اطياف الطيف السياسي في مصر حول هذا
الموضوع اما الان في ظل الاستقطاب الحالي
فللاسف الشعب منقسم الى عده فئات وكل فئه
تنظر الى القضاء كما تنظر الى شيء اخر من
منظورها الخاص الذي اعتقد انه نسبيا قصير
النظر لكن سيد مختار انت تقول ليس هنالك
نضوج بعد بين الفئتين من قسيمتين لدى
الشعب لكن هل القاده ناضج قبل ان اتحدث عن
الشعب لانه عاده ما القائد هو يوجه جمهوره
هل القاده ناضج للمصالحه بالقرارات التي
يتخذونها القاده من من كافه الاطراف غير
ناضجين للمصالحه والقاده هم نتاج للشعب
يعني في تفاعل ما بين الشعب والقاده ولكن
هناك ثقافه مشتركه هذه الثقافه اصبحت الان
عباره عن يعني نوع من التعصب السياسي او
المذهبي بعباره ادق فاجابه على سؤالك احب
اقول كمان انه في 25 يناير ثبت ان الشباب
الذي بدا ثوره 25 يناير اكثر نضجا من
القاد ولا اعتقد ان هذا قد تغير الان و
لهذا سالتك السؤال يعني انت عن الشعب وعن
القاده لان يبدو للبعض ان القاده اكثر
رعونه من الشعب مثلا حتى يعني مفترض اي
مثلا كان ان يطبق من خلال خريطه الطريق
ميثاق الشرف الاعلامي رايت الاعلام المصري
لم يطبق فيه هذا الميثاق بالتالي من
المسؤول عن تمادي الشعب ان كان متمادي في
تعصبه لهذه الفئه او
لهذا
المسؤول عده حاجات من ضمنها ثقافه بيشترك
فيها الجميع يعني هذه الثقافه اللي هي
فيها اللي انتجت هذا التمادي ليست نتاج
فقط لهؤلاء القاده قد تكون في جزء من
الاجزاء لكن هم ايضا نتاج لها وهذه
الثقافه نحن جميعا مسؤولين عنها انا
التقسيمه اللي شايفها بوضوح دلوقتي ليست
بين فئات سياسيه بقدر ما هي بين اجيال وهي
التقسيمه التي سوف تتحكم في المستقبل بين
اجيال بين اجيال بين الشباب من ناحيه وبين
الشيوخ من ناحيه اخرى يعني دع دعينا نقول
افتراضا بينما هم تحت ال 40 45 ومن هم فوق
هذهه تستاهل النقاش وثانيه واحده و خلص
وعلى كل القطاعات يعني انا اتصور ان شباب
الاخوان اللي في العشرينات اقرب الى
الشباب في العشرينات الليبراليين منهم الى
قادتهم ا وان القاده الليبراليين اقرب الى
قاده الاخوان والسلفيه منهم الى شبابهم ا
دكتور اذا بالنسبه لمختار كامل هو صراع
بين اجيال هنالك جيل متمسك بافكاره غير
قابل للانفتاح سواء من هذا الطرف او من
ذاك وجيل اخر ايضا يعني مختلف عنه بانه
قابل انفتاح لكن لم تتح له الفرصه ان كان
صح التعبير هل هذا في مكانه نعم هذا صحيح
جدا وتاكيدا على كلام استاذنا مختار كامل
هناك فجوه كبيره بين داخل التيارات
السياسيه ان نفسها هناك فجوه بين ما يمكن
ما يطلق عليه فجوه بين القواعد وبين
القيادات هذه الفجوه نشات من ان ان هناك
برج عجي يعيش فيه القيادات استنادا الى
تاريخ استنادا الى فكر استنادا الى نمط
تنشئه او عباده تنظيم او عباده طيار او
عباده فكره وللاسف الشديد تجاهلوا كل
القيم الثوريه التي اكتسبها الشباب من
مختلف التيارات السياسيه من احتكاكهم شبه
الدائم بشكل يومي في الميدان التحرير وفي
غيره من ميادين من ميادين مصر اسمحي لي
فقط اعود الى جزئيه نضج القاده وكيف يمكن
ان يكون مبررا هذه اشكاليه في منتهى
الخطوره وللاسف الشديد ايضا منذ الانقلاب
العسكري لم يكن هناك رشد كما ذكر الاستاذ
مختار بين قيادات كل الطيارات ولكن معدلات
الرشد كانت ادنى درجه بين قده الانقلاب
بين قده الانقلاب من خلال عده مؤشرات
المؤشر الاول ما كان يعلن عن فعاليه من
الفعاليات لمعارضي الانقلاب الا ويتم
تصدير الشعب حتى يصبح شعبا في مقابل شعب
او تيار في مقابل تيار وبالتالي تحدث
المجازر حدث هذا ن شعب وانتم شعب هذه
اغنيه ح لا غير الاغنيه بخلاف الاغنيه كان
يتم تصدير هذا المشهد الى الشارع على
الارض وليس على الفضائيات نعم هذه ح حدث
حدث الامر في 24 يوليو عندما دعا
المعارضون الانقلاب لجمعه ملي يونيه يوم
الجمعه فخرج قائد الانقلاب ليدعو الى الى
تفويض والتعبير عن هذا التفويض بالنزول
الى الشارع حدث هذا ايضا عندما دعى
المعارضون الانقلاب الى الاحتفال احياء
ذكرى 6 اكتوبر فدع القوات المسلحه الى
النزول الى الشارع في مواجهه المحتجين هذا
عن نطج القاده نطج القاده الان لا يجب ان
ان نطالب كما نطالب قيادات الجماعه
الجماعات الاسلاميه وتحديدا الاخوان
المسلمين بالتعامل مع الحدث والقبول
بالمبادرات التي تطرح والقبول بالترضي
التي تصرح اين النداءات والتو المطالب
التي توجه الى قاره الانقلاب في الطرف
الاخر الامر يحتاج الى اعاده نظر في من
يملك السلطه الان ومن يملك القدره على
الفعل والتنفيذ اشكاليه اخرى في غايه
الاهميه
للامانه دائما في مرحله ما بعد الثورات او
بعد التحولات السياسيه الجذريه تصار قضيه
كبرى للاسف تجاهلنا عليها تجاهلناها في
مصر تجاهلناها في سوريا تجاهلناها في في
اليمن تجاهلناها في ليبيا وهي قضيه
العداله الانتقاليه قضيه العداله
الانتقاليه استنادا لكل المؤشرات وكل كل
المواثيق الدوليه لديها مجموعه من الركائز
الاساسيه الركيزه الاولى هي معرفه الحقيقه
ركائز علميه معريه معتمده ركائز علميه
معتمده هناك مراكز علميه متخصصه هناك
تشريعات ملزمه مجموعه من الركائز الاساسيه
ست ركائز اساسيه للعداله الانتقاليه ويمكن
هذه الركائز السته يمكن ان تكون مدخلا
اساسيا لفكره المصالحه اذا كان هناك
مصالحه او اذا كانت فكره المصالحه مقبوله
بالاساس من قاره الانقلاب العسكري الركائز
السته هي معرفه الحقيقه ده ابتداء ثانيا
المحاسبه والقصاص ثالثا تعويض الضحايا
وجبر الضرر معرفه الحقيقه المحاسبه
والقصاص تعويض الضحايا وجبر الضرر الاصلاح
المؤسسي تطهير المؤسسات القضائيه ا والاهم
ثم كل هذه المقدمات الخمسه تقود في
النهايه الى المصالحه لا يمكن الحديث عن
مصالحه قبل استكمال الركائز الخمس الاولى
لا يمكن الحديث عن مصالحه قبل معرفه
الحقيقه لا يمكن الحديث عن مصالحه قبل
المحاسبه والقصاص من كل من اجرم في حق هذا
الش لم يحدث 25 حتى
الان لا مجال للحديث عن مصالحه الان او
غدا او بعد عام قبل توفير هذه الركائز
الخمسه اي حديث عن مصالحه ستكون شكليه
لانه للاسف الشديد ايضا بعد 3 يوليو لكن
اليست الان مصالحه من نوع اخر يعني كانت
هنالك عداله انتقاليه مفترض ان تحصل او لم
تحصل بعد 25 يناير والان نتحدث عن مصالحه
بعد انقلاب الثالث من يوليو هل يتماهى
الامران ام هذا الشيء وهذا شيء استاذ بعد
3 يوليو سلطه الانقلاب انشات وزاره اطلقت
عليها وزاره العداله الانتقاليه والمصالحه
الوطنيه تمام
ثم شكلت مجموعه من اللجان لتقصي الحقائق
هذا ابتداء هذه اجراءات الاكن للاسف
الشديد اجراءات مهمه ومطلوبه تشكيل وزاره
خاصه للمح عبره في تطبيقها ومن
يطبقها يعني اصلا بنينا الحلقه على مساله
الانتقائيه في القضا البعض ياخذ براءه
والاخر
اسمحيلي لا انا ا حضرتك الاسوا ان وزير
الوزير المعني بعده الانتقاليه وتحقيق
المصالحه الوطنيه خرج عبر وسائل الاعلام
في 24 ديسمبر ويقول ان التيارات
المتظاهرون في الشارع جماعات ارهابيه
متطرفه وهم السبب في كل ما تحدث اليه من
الكوارث وبالتالي لا مجال للمصالحه ساعود
اليك دكتور شكرا لك فاصل قصير اتوقف معه
نناقش بعده مطلوبات الخروج من حاله الصدام
القائمه بين سلطات الانقلاب ومعارضيها في
مصر ابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد سيد مختار كامل دعنا
نكون حالمين قليلا لكي يعني نرغب انت تقول
الناس غير ناضجه للمصالحه دعنا نحاول ان
نرغبه بذلك ونحلم فلنقل ان المصالحه حصلت
ما نتائجها تكون على
مصر السؤال ده صعب جدا انا بحاول اتخيل
المصالحه تحصل ازاي خد
وقتك لو المصالحه حصلت يبقى انا اتصور ان
هيبقى في عدد من الاحزاب
السياسيه الموجوده التي تتنافس على الساحه
السياسيه بمنتهى العدل في ظل عمليه سياسيه
تساوي بين الجميع في الترشيح للانتخابات
من ناحيه القوى الماديه القوى الماليه
يعني للاعلان الدخول الى وسائل الاعلام
الى اخر هذا الكلام اتصور كمان لو
المصالحه حصلت انه هتبقى المصريه هي اساس
الذي يشترك فيه الجميع وهي الجذر الذي
تتفرع منه مختلف العقائد السياسيه من يسار
الى يمين الى اسلام الى غيره اتصور ايضا
ان موضوع التحزب الديني سوف يقل تماما وان
الذين يدعون الى التحزب الديني من
المسلمين والمسيحيين على اساس ان الهويه
هي هويه دينيه وليست وطنيه اساسا ان هذا
سوف يقل تماما ومن يدعو لذلك سوف يكون من
الاقليات ومن المطاريد وبالتالي اتصور انه
لو حدث ذلك معنى ذلك اننا تبنينا مبادئ
ثوره 25 يناير معنى ذلك اننا اصبحنا على
نفس المستوى الذكاء والاخلاق الذي ابداه
شباب مصر من 25 يناير الى 11 فبراير في
2011 ا طيب بعد ان قرب لنا الصوره عن
ايجابيات المصالحه سيد مختار كامل اعتقد
انك توافقه بالنتيجه لهذه المصالحه اريد
منك دكتور ان تقول لي شروط هذه المصالحه
متطلباتها م اي كل طرف ماذا ماذا يحصل
وعما يتنازل على ما يحصل وعما يتنازل حتى
يلتقيا على ارضيه مشتركه وتنبت المصالحه
وتستفيد مصر هذه احلام كما ذكرت حضرتك هذه
احلام لكن احيانا يمكن ان تحقق احلام لا
مجال للاحلام للاسف الشديد لا مجال
الاحلام في مصر الان مصر ده تسير الى
منزلق شديد الخطوره لان هناك طرفين
اساسيين للمعادله الانقلاب ومن خلفه
ومعارضه الانقلاب الانقلاب ومن خلفه لديهم
ممارسات اجراميه يجب ان يحاسبوا عليها
ويحاكم عليها كل من اجرم في حق هذا الشعب
لابد ان يحاسب ابتداء من قائد الانقلاب
هذا اولا دكتور اسمح لي يعني حتى انا فقط
اردت ان اكون ايجابيه بعض الشيء ومتفائله
لكن ماذا لو جرى
اي يعني حلت يعني ربما لا ادري اعجوبه ما
وخففت الاحكام القضائيه اطلق سراح
الابرياء من السجون الصحفيون هذا لا يساعد
طب وما تحقق من دماء
سقطت الاف الدماء التي سقطت كيف يتم
تعويضها ابتداء الاف قدرات الد مقدرات
الدوله التي تم اهدارها وانكها كيف يتم
تعوضها هذا ثانيا هناك ثارات في الشارع
الان بين بين ملايين الاسر وملايين
الافراد في حق الجميع تحدثت انتهاكات هناك
كما ذكرت طرفين للمعادله الكل اجرم في حق
هذا الوطن سواء المؤيد او المعارض المؤيد
او المعارض المطلوب الان ان تشك للاسف
الشديد المطلوب
يعتبر شبه مستحيل لاننا المطلوب فعلا ان
تشهد مصر ثوره حقيقيه تطهر مصر من كل
الفاسدين المجرمين من كل التيارات
السياسيه دون استثناء وبالتالي ر لابد ان
تمر للاسف الشديد لابد ان تمر مصر مصر
بهذا المازق مصر مقدمه فعلا على مرحله
شديده السوء شديده التردي شديده الانهيار
شديده الخطوره اذا لم يدرك اذا لم يدرك
عقلاء هذا الوطن وحكماه طبيعه المرحله وما
يمكن ان تنجر اليه مصر التحذيرات الكثيره
او التهت الكثيره التي تقول مصر ليست
سوريا ومصر ليست ليبيا ومصر ليست اليمن او
غيرها للاسف الشديد مصر تحمل كل بذور هذا
هذا الانقسام وهذا الانشقاق الحديث عن اي
مصالحه لابد ان يتعامل مع الواقع كما هو
الان هناك ثارات للالاف خلقت على الارض
هناك دماء سالت من المؤيدين ومن المعارضين
لابد ان تحصل على تعويض لهذه الدماء هناك
من اجرم في حق هذا الشعب لابد ان يحاسب
على ما ارتكب من جرائم ايا كان اسمه او
شخصه او وزنه او التيار السياسي او الفكر
الذي ينتمي اليه هذا ابتداء كما ذكرت
لحضرتك في الجزء السابق لدينا مجموعه من
المؤشرات الاساسيه او الركائز الاساسيه
التي يجب توفيرها وهي ما مكونات او ركائز
فكره العداله الانتقاليه اذا تحققت او
اقتربنا من تحقيق مثل هذه المؤشرات وهذا
شبه مستحيل في هذه المرحله لاننا امام
قائد انقلاب اعلن صراحه انه لا مجال
للمصالحه كيف يمكن الحديث عن المصالحه
وهذا اعلن اعلن هذا صراحه وللامانه ايضا
انه لا يملك القدره على ال قيام بهذه
المصالحه لان من يقف خلفه يجبره على مسار
خطه له وهو مجرد اداه هو لم يطبق ميثاق
شرف اعلامي ما بالك بمصالحه وب لا هذا
اخطر هذا اخطر ميثاق شرف اعلامي امر في في
مصر يمكن بكلمه واحده يمكن تطبيقه و ا اه
في اطار قمعي ولكن فكره المصالحه غير
وارده لان هذا الرجل جاء لتحقيق هدف واضح
ومحدد وهو القضاء على التيارات السياسيه
ذات المرجعيه الاسلاميه في مصر ابتداء
والسيطره على السلطه لتعزيز مصالح وحمايه
مصالح عدد من القوى الاقليميه والدوليه في
المنطقه وبالتالي هذه الدول تقف خلفه ولا
يمكن له او لا يستطيع على الاقل في
العامين القادمين الخروج عن الصف او
مخالفه من يقف ويقدم له الدعم السياسي
والاقتصادي استيد مختار كامل اذا لا يمكن
ان يقف بوجه من يدعمه ويغير المعادله او
او السكه التي تمشي عليها مصر
الان اولا احب اقول انا لما انا فهمت كلمه
المصالحه ليس فقط بين قطبين وهو التيار
الاسلامي اولا ثم اليارات المدنيه او
التيار الحاكم ثانيا وفقط انا قصدت
المصالحه بين كافه التيارات السياسيه بما
فيها التيار الاسلامي اتفق مع الدكتور
عصام فان ده له شروط غير متوفره في
التيارات السياسيه حاليا بما فيها
بالتاكيد التيار الاسلامي ا اما اذا كان
السيسي ولكن سيد مختار اسمح لي فقط في هذه
النقطه بالتحديد تفضلي هنالك الكثير من
المما خذ على التيار الاسلامي وعلى
الاخوان وهنالك اراء تقول مثلا من العوائق
التي تقف في وجه المصالحه تشتت القرار
الاخواني عدم وجود قائد الاخواني لديه
استعداد للتضحيه والتنازل التحالف ما يسمى
بتحالف اخواني اقليمي كل ذلك طيب اوكي
نعرفها وانت تعرفها لكن في المقابل لو
نظرت الى الامور الان انت ترى يعني هنالك
رقم قياسي في اصدار احكام بالاعدام رقم
قياسي فقط لانهم معارضون للحكم
الحالي طيب كيف يمكن هنا ان تضعهما في نفس
الكفه لا انا ما كنتش بتكلم دلوقتي عن
احكام الاعدام انا كنت بتكلم عن موضوع
المصالحه ممكن نتكلم عن احكام الاعدام بس
اللي انا عايز اقوله لا اعطيك مثلا
الاحكام كمثل عن باد النيه عن النوايا
المسبقه شوف حضرتك احكام الاعدام هذه انا
اكلمت عنها في اول سؤال لكي وقلت لك انها
بادره سيئه ويعني مش فقل خير اللي عايز
اقوله انه معظم الشعوب العربيه هي في
جوهرها تربيتها تربيه سلفيه الشعوب
العربيه السنيه ذات تربيه سلفيه في جوهرها
يعني السيسي اللي بيهاجم بيقولوا ان ده
قائد انقلاب هذا الرجل اتربى تربيه سلفيه
زي ما انا اتربيت تربيه سلفيه زي ما زعماء
وهنا المسؤوليه الخطيره التي تقع على عاتق
تيار الاسلام السياسي والتي تفوق مسؤوليه
اي تيار اخر لان هذا التيار وهو يعلم ان
الدين شكل جزءا عظيما من وجدان هذه الشعوب
لم يقم باي عمليه تصحيح او تطوير او تحديث
او ترقيه اخلاقيه للناس انما علمهم مجرد
الالتزام بالشعائر وهو يرى هذا التفسخ
الاخلاقي في البلاد مع هذا الفقه الديني
دون ان يقوم باي انت الان انت الان تحاسب
الاخوان وتيار السياسي الاسلام التي الا
السياسي طيب هذا يعني عوقبوا الم يعاقبوا
بما يكفي بعد انا مش مسؤول عن ان يعني
اقصد ايه انا مش عايز ان هو يعاقب انا
عايز حل انا لا اطلب العقاب الحل زي ما
قال الدكتور عصام ان الجماعه دولت زي
غيرهم كل تيار سياسي يجب ان يتطور من
الداخل بما يتواكب مع الم ط ولكن هذا لا
يستقيم مع الحل الذي يطبق الان من قبل
سلطات الانقلاب سياسه الاقصاء والقبضه
الحديديه لا توصلك الى النتيجه التي تطالب
بها لا لا توصل طبعا انا قلت 50 مره ان
القبضه الحديديه فات اوانها وللاسف ان في
جزء من الشعب بينادي بهذه القبضه الحديديه
تحت تاثير تحريض الاعلم كما ذكرت لك دكتور
نعم هناك اشكاليه مهمه جدا جدا دائما ما
نلق بال المسؤوليه على القوى التيارات
السياسيه المعرضه للانقلاب اذكر حضرتك
واذكر كل المشاهدين ان التيارات السياسيه
المعارضه للانقلاب لا يمر اسبوع او لا يمر
شهر الا وتطرح مبادره للتسويه اخرها
مبادره مطروحه بالامس طرحها حزب الاستقلال
عن تسويه سيا سياسيه في الداخل المصري
وبتال تخلي عن السلطه لي ليست تسويه فكره
هذه
مرسخ نحن نريد تسويه من الطرفين ل الفكره
ليست في في طبيعه التسويه الفكره ان هناك
من يبادر ايا كانت طبيعه المبادره عليها
تحفظات قابله للتعديل قابله لاعاده النظر
قابله للتطوير المهم من يبادر من يبادر
بالوصول الى حل الازمات التي تع هك طرف
واحد يبادر اقل من دقيقه ما يجب التاكيد
عليه الان ان دوله الظلم مهما طالت ساعه
ودوله العدل الى قيام الساعه هذا مؤشر رجب
اخذه في الاعتبار شكرا جزيلا لك بهذا اختم
هذه الحلقه دكتور عصام عبد الشافي استاذ
العلوم السياسيه ومختار كامل رئيس تحالف
مصريين الامريكيين كنت معي في الاستديو
اهلا وسهلا بكم بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ن